before we get to this headphones war by
this guy no lis its Taylor Swift really
this powerful well I think what this
reflects is well certainly she's very
very popular but i think this also
reflects apples anxiety about its place
in the new music ecosystem Apple is
coming to this in coming to this
battlefield a little bit late there are
startup services like Spotify that are
off the ground and there's some question
whether Apple despite all of its
firepower will compete successfully and
I think what you're seeing there is a
lot of uneasiness within Apple such that
they're willing to as you say back down
in 24 hours based on a little social
media harassment from just one artist
there's a lot of flux in this in this
whole this whole segment it's very
interesting move by Apple but they've
got another headache on their hands
right so it's his battle with this guy
no Lee tell me right right well this is
actually related in a way to the Taylor
Swift Apple music thing Noli is a guy
who started a company called monster
cable and they've made audio accessories
going all the way back to the late 1970s
monster was also the company that
manufactured beats headphones the
phenomenally successful headphones that
are backed by dr.dre the hip-hop legend
and jimmy iovine the producer mogul and
in 2014 Beats Electronics was sold to
Apple for three billion dollars no Lee
has now piped up sued beats electronics
which is effectively Apple now and said
I should have been cut in on that deal
because I'm the guy who actually
designed and manufactured those
headphones so now we've got kind of a
classic business fight in court over who
deserves credit for these iconic
headphones